i'm greg gutfeld i'm martha mccallum i'm
brett bear and this is the fox news
rundown
wednesday april 13th 2022 i'm jared
halpern a republican primary in georgia
is testing the endorsement of former
president trump without trump's
endorsement kemp cannot get the voters
that he needs out we speak with former
senator and georgia gubernatorial
candidate david perdue i'm chris foster
former attorney general william barr
spent two as he puts it tumultuous years
working for president trump describing
it in his new book and the title as one
damn thing after another i did the best
i could on each issue that came to me
and then i did what i thought was right
and justified under the law of facts
and not play games and i'm david marcus
i've got the final word on the fox news
rundown
[Music]
voters in georgia could have a rematch
this year in the race for governor
incumbent republican brian kemp is
running for a second term he narrowly
defeated democrat stacey abrams four
years ago abrams is the far and away
front-runner for democrats this year
kemp is also a front-runner but facing a
challenge from former senator david
perdue who has the backing of former
president trump he has to win the trump
voter and he's done nothing but fight
trump for the last two years kemp was on
the fox news rundown yesterday today
a chat with perdue about why he's
challenging a fellow republican he
worked closely with when both held
statewide office i do not believe that
brian kemp can beat stacey abrams for
the simple reason that he has to win
republicans he has to win the women in
the suburbs and he has to win the trump
voter and he's done nothing but fight
trump for the last two years and
certainly when we see the lack of
involvement in investigating any of the
facts that are now beginning to come out
i can't see how these people who are
upset about the election are going to
vote for it then in addition to that
he's divided the party over several
other issues the buckhead city vote for
one
these are the things that have split the
party and so what i've done is decided
to just give people a choice in this
primary as to who they think can stand
up and beat stacey abrams well let me
ask
i want to talk about that aspect of it
but let's start with the election stuff
the governor kemp supported got past
that election integrity bill i know you
were a supporter of that i believe
um he has moved proposals that a lot of
democrats say are dangerous but that
republicans have called for when it
comes to election integrity what else
would you do as governor
well first of all go back to 2020. i
would have not let that consent decree
get signed i mean i would have fought
that with everything i had they
fundamentally turned the elections over
to stacey abrams they changed law really
by edict things like they allowed money
to be donated directly to campaign
election
boards in certain counties zuckerberg
put 55 million dollars in here doing
things like mobile voting buses and so
forth now some of that has changed in
the law that i did support i didn't go i
said publicly it didn't go far enough if
you're not going to check signatures
which did not happen in 2020 what makes
people think that in those democratic
counties they're going to check social
security numbers or driver's licenses so
my thing has been about the enforcement
of the law to date no real outside
investigation has been had although the
secretary of state the governor all say
oh no it's all been looked at it's all
been debunked well that's not true
if you look at the court case that
voters brought against fulton county
alone just that one case the judge ruled
that the evidence was compelling and he
ruled to unseal the ballot now before
they did that he ruled that the
voters do not have legal standing and he
dismissed the case now that case is in
appeal and i believe it will win on
appeal
but i can't wait that long i want to get
the answers now but it's governor that's
in the court system already what there's
nothing a governor can do to change the
judge's mind no i agree but the fact
that he didn't even investigate he's
telling everybody that had a clean
election is being denounced by a civil
court that's the point i'm trying to
make so his denial that anything
happened in 2020 and that there are no
facts that support the illegal activity
during the election is just not founded
in truth so that's the point i'm trying
to make there right now he could
absolutely initiate a gbi georgia bureau
of investigation investigation into
ballot trafficking and ballot harvesting
that's the first thing he should do he
saw this evidence in may the first time
i saw it in may as well and he has done
nothing in fact that he has impeded that
you see testimony now being given by the
people who actually did the
investigation from true the vote that
said that the governor's office actually
leaked names of people that were
involved so that was very detrimental to
the investigation that's the first thing
that should happen and that's those are
the points that a lot of people are very
upset about
in the state of georgia
what would you propose be passed moving
forward
from the civil legislative point of view
yeah it's a great question very simply
number one it's not the laws it's the
fact that we don't enforce the law i'll
give you the straight answer and i'll
give you the reasons why you need this
first of all i would propose and have
publicly a law enforcement agency
dedicated solely to enforcing voting
laws the second thing is any statewide
elected office that has to be certified
would have to have an outside audit this
is a truly independent audit not done by
the sectarian state and the third thing
is i've said publicly we'd get rid of
these voting machines that have most
people have lost confidence in them so
those are things i would do here's why
law enforcement is is absolutely
imperative if you go back and look at
what happened in november of 2020 in
dekalb county and in fulton county two
among nine that had this problem these
are mainly democratic counties the cab
only had nine absentee ballots jared
that were rejected because of a bad
signature match in fulton county only 10
out of 147 000 so it's pretty obvious
they were not checking signatures
there's even people who have made those
statements that the signatures are not
being checked so i went back and looked
in 2016 we had the same low rate of
rejection of bad ballots because of bad
signature matches and that's when brian
kemp was secretary of state so we did
not enforce the law even when he was
secretary of state and all i'm saying is
if you have a law that's supposed to
check the identity of an absentee ballot
voter then that absolutely ballot voter
should have to comply with the law
that's all i'm saying correct me if i'm
wrong but it sounds like what you were
proposing would take
oversight of the state's elections away
from the constitutional officer
that is supposed to have oversight of
the state's elections
no what the secretary of state has
already been removed as chairman of the
state election board they did that in
this bill that they talk about
so what i'm saying is that i want the
law in force they have changed the law
the law right now just to use one
example says that an an absentee voter
uh has to supply their driver's license
or or social security number or some id
number and that has to be matched to an
official record well if they're not
matching it then we're not enforcing the
law so in effect voter id for absentee
ballots was not in effect in
several counties in georgia in 2020
but the new law addresses that
it does but only if enforced the last
law addressed that it had signature
verification if they had done that
and looked at national averages then we
probably wouldn't be sitting here
talking i probably wouldn't be running
for uh the governorship i mean so that's
sort of the point i was i guess trying
to get to with sort of all these
questions about the election aspect is
that's really like the only issue
that you don't see pretty much eye to
eye with with governor kemp on right oh
i mean
on on education issues on a lot of these
other issues seem to be
pretty locked step no
no not at all i really didn't realize in
december how different we view things
let me give you an example economic
development i want to get rid of the
state income tax we've got to become
more competitive and so i propose
getting rid of standing up takes the
governor says you can't do that with
regard to economic development i believe
in creating jobs i know how to do that
i've done it my entire business career
but
to do it the way they just did with
rivian where they cram it down the
throat of local community they got no
say in the matter and no involvement in
how it was going to be done and so forth
and to do it with a company that is
owned primarily by george soros and to
give hundreds of millions of dollars
taxpayer dollars to a company owned by
george soros with no disclosure they
have not even disclosed the total amount
of that yet the third part of that is
that there were six or seven people who
own land down there they're gonna make
125 million dollars
with grossly inflated prices like sixty
thousand dollars an acre on average uh
which is dramatically higher than you
know almost six times higher than the
average uh land cost in that area of
georgia uh the slush fund we took him to
court on this jarrod and one the court
said that his slush fund super pac was
unconstitutional and he put a stay on it
uh now instead of being reprimanded the
governor actually doubled down it just
shows that they think that it's okay to
have an unlevel playing field when it
comes to getting re-elected how would
you make up the revenue if you got rid
of the state income tax well i'm working
with art laffer who is a world-renowned
uh economy or he is a world renowned
economist he was reagan's economist he
was trump's economist and we're working
on first of all you have to rationalize
the tax credits and deductions on the
sales tax side there's revenue to be
gained there second of all you do the
same thing on the state income tax side
and then thirdly you look at the current
state of play we have a four billion
dollar surplus right now i'm proposing
to go ahead and reduce the rate one
percentage point from five seven five to
four seven five this is something that
you're going to see other states begin
to do from a competitive point of view
and georgia certainly can be a leader in
that let me talk a little bit about
where you started where you said you
entered this race because you do not
believe that governor kemp uh can win
statewide he has a record of beating the
democratic front-runner in stacy abrams
in your most recent election you lost to
a democrat what's your message to
republican voters who want to know why
that situation is different now well
first of all brian kemp had donald
trump's endorsement back in 18. he
certainly does not have that right now
so he can't get the trump voter out the
second is let's look at the facts in
november of 2020 had governor kemp not
caved into stacey abrams i'd be in the
united states senate today i'm clear on
that
even with the illegal activity that we
think happened in november 2020 we
produce 90 000 votes more than the
democrat 49.8 or whatever we missed the
50 rule right by you know just a few
thousand votes but in that election we
produced 480 000 votes more than brian
kemp did in 2018 only because we were
able to pull all facets of the party
together that's what kemp cannot do this
year he could have if he'd done the
right thing if he'd investigated
anything relative to the election so
that's the clear logic without trump's
endorsement kemp cannot get the voters
that he needs out why do you think
that's not resonating yet in the polls
polls don't pick stuff like that up you
saw that in 2014 jared when i was
running then they had me down eight to
ten points in the general election
against michelle nunn
uh we won by eight points the same thing
held true in 2020 in that election i'm
just telling you i'm running around the
state right now i don't believe these
polls are picking up the energy and
intensity of the people who really want
to see change they believe illegal
activity happened they want somebody to
be held accountable and they want it
fixed and that's what i'm proposing
let me ask this as somebody who's run
you know to your point a few times in
the state of georgia have you seen some
of these these shifts i mean obviously
georgia's now
you know kind of considered a purplish
state
well let's look at the facts jared in
november 2020 when five million people
voted the democrats could only get 47
and a half percent period
that's not even close to 50. and by the
way that includes the illegal activity
that now is coming out that's pretty
obvious that happened they still
couldn't get more than 47.5
so what i'm seeing out here is the fact
that i think a lot of marginal
republicans people aren't very involved
in in the political structure are now
involved because they feel like that
their vote was not counted properly that
means their voice wasn't heard and
people get very upset in a
representative democracy when that
happens and i think you're going to see
that in the turnout you know only about
one out of every three republicans
typically vote in a primary that may
change this time let me finish with this
if
governor kemp is able to win this
primary are you prepared to
support him over the democratic front
runner or the democratic nominee likely
i guess stacey abrams 100 look my goal
here
is to make sure that in 2024 we have a
republican conservative in the white
house the only way to do that is to win
this governor's job this governor's race
is going to be a national race against
stacey abrams she wants to be president
united states he's using this race as a
stepping stone to that end
and certainly i will make sure that we
do everything we can at the state of
georgia to get all republicans out to
stop stacey abrams from being governor
of georgia
i always appreciate our conversations
appreciate the time senator uh we'll
continue to have these conversations
thanks so much i hope so thank you jared
i appreciate it
[Music]
this is david marcus with your fox news
commentary coming up william barr was
attorney general twice from 1991 to 93
in the george h.w bush administration
then brought in by president trump as
his ag in early 2019 two years into his
administration bill barr will be
nominated
for the united states attorney general
position i think he will serve with
great distinction so william barr has
been at the center or just off to the
side of some of the biggest events and
stories of the last 30 plus years the
gulf war supreme court confirmation
fights the russia election interference
investigation an impeachment the covet
pandemic and the 2020 election he says
he was reluctant to take the job the
second time i didn't want to go into the
government for a host of reasons mainly
you know my own lifestyle was terrific
at that point william barr's book out
now is called one damn thing after
another memoirs of an attorney general
but i i saw that the country was
careening sort of toward a potential
constitutional crisis the russia gate
thing was being used to
hurt the president and potentially even
drive him from office and smother the
administration and
a lot of people thought that the
department needed
someone like me who knew the department
and could could run it and get confirmed
by the senate and
i eventually became persuaded that
if the president asked me i would do it
because you're doing it for the country
you're doing it
uh for the you know to keep these
important institutions functioning
properly and so i said okay well if he
asked me i will do it and he talked to
me and asked me to do it so i accept it
so you would basically talk yourself
into it before you met with him if if
the offer you said you're gonna do it
yeah my view was
they had asked me to go and talk to the
people that asked me to go and talk to
the president about it and i said i'm
not going to talk to him unless i could
actually accept the job otherwise it's a
waste of his time
and so i had to sort of cross that
bridge mentally before i even went to
talk to him that if he decided
he needed me that i should be prepared
to do it so
i talked it through with my family
my three daughters who were lawyers and
members of my family and my son-in-laws
were in the department and so it would
affect them too
and so we talked it through and everyone
thought at the end of the day that i was
in the best position to stabilize things
at the department if i was asked
and so that's that's how we got there
uh the mueller investigation is one of
those things that you are obviously
aligned with president trump on um right
and there were
there's this media narrative excuse but
forgive me for using the word but you've
used the word that you were a toady for
the president yeah um but but there may
there were just things that you happen
to agree with them on not that you were
carrying out his bidding right
yeah so you know i i
was uh committed in my own mind that the
only way to get through this it's uh
during these times was to
just make sure that i did the best i
could on each issue that came to me and
then i did what i thought was right and
justified under the law of facts
and not play games and i told the
president that in the criminal justice
area that's what i would do we can't
have politics determining what we do in
the criminal justice sphere
and he agreed and that's how i handled
it and it as you say just it just so
happens that
the way i handled the russia gate which
was which was a completely uh
false narrative that was being used as a
weapon against the president these were
decisions based on the merits i knew
they would hurt me politically because
the media would use them to advance
their narrative but at the end of the
day i have to be fair to the individual
that's what our justice system is about
but there were things that the president
wanted me to do
he didn't tell me directly but it was
obvious from his tweets and his behavior
he wanted to see
scalps
brought before the election because that
could be helpful to him
you know on the durham investigation and
so forth uh but we were not in a
position to do it the the investigation
took a long time longer than we'd like
largely because of kovid that frozen a
lot of things
but mike wasn't going to do something
just to
use the criminal justice process to help
him politically that would have been
wrong and an abuse and he was very
frustrated by that yeah the donald trump
the donald trumpness about him that got
him elected in the first place is
his personality who he is
you say probably cost him the election
the second time around
just by the way he handled covert for
example how did the how did his
qualities hurt his handling of the
pandemic just as an example
so you know i i i say that his his some
of his qualities actually helped him in
2016
uh because people were very frustrated
and because it helped him blow through
the
mainstream media smothering uh of
his viewpoints and so forth so he was he
was somewhat effective because of those
traits but in 2020 they didn't work
they basically alienated a lot of the
suburban voters and he was told for
about a year that he was going to lose
the election unless
you know he tempered some of his
obnoxious behavior and
i think that his handling of
covid was a mixed bag but generally uh
you know he was hurt by it
but i think what was decisive wasn't so
much covet but the kind of attributes he
showed in the first debate you know sort
of uh
cranky belligerent sometimes petty
and polling had showed that he was going
to lose
many of the key suburbs because of that
and that's ultimately what happened
he did not try to
correct for that and i think that's why
he lost the election you know he
he
sixty thousand people went to the polls
in pennsylvania and voted republican
except for him
he ran weaker than the statewide
republican ticket
and and the members of congress that
were running for reelection
if if you're going to run behind the
republican party in arizona wisconsin
pennsylvania you're going to lose the
election and that's what happened um
you resigned a little shy of a month
early you didn't buy that the election
was stolen some people still do or at
least are pretending to believe it
because trump supporters do um is
election fraud a big problem and do you
worry that fraud or maybe more
importantly the perception of fraud
going forward
are just par for the course in every
presidential election now
no i don't think they have to be and i
am worried about fraud and i'm worried
about you know
things that that undermine the integrity
and the public acceptance of election
results anything that dilutes the
safeguards in an election
to make sure that the votes are kosher
anything that dilutes that is going to
cause people to doubt the outcome and
that's what we're seeing now and that's
true whether or not you can ultimately
prove fraud it's very hard to prove
fraud it's very hard to
cure fraud after the fact
that's why you have to have the
protections in place at the time of the
election that's why i was against
universal mail and ballots and things
like that and i spoke out strongly
about that before the election
so i think the thing to do is what the
governors in georgia and texas have been
doing which is tightening up the rules
in the states the states are responsible
for
those rules and they should be tightened
up and the parties have to be in the
republican party has to be very vigilant
because the democratic party seemed i
think they're playing with fire because
they seem to be prepared to have
elections based on the honor system well
no one's going to trust the outcome of
those elections and then we're in you
know some very dark times if people
don't think the elections have any
integrity and that's what we're seeing
right now distrust
you predicted that uh russian president
vladimir putin would be emboldened by
president biden's election that biden
would be seen as weak and um this
obviously isn't in the book because you
didn't write the book in the last couple
of months but um now we're seeing what
we're seeing uh in ukraine
former national security adviser john
bolton and some other people have said
look putin was just waiting to see if
trump was re-elected that trump would
have let putin just waltz into
ukraine on a post what do you think
would be happening now if trump was
president
i think probably if trump had been
elected
i think there probably would have been a
period where we sat down with the
russians and engaged with them and tried
to work out some modis
of ending with the russians
uh where that would you know whether
that was something that was feasible
whether we could reach a meeting of the
mines that assured the russians you know
that
that they weren't their military
security wasn't being imperiled by nato
or the expansion of nato i don't know
but i think there would have been a an
i'm confident there would have been an
effort toward that because i think
the way uh
i think we saw the world was that china
is the long-term very serious danger to
us and we need to
stabilize things in europe uh we can't
afford to have you know
separate crises one with russia and one
with china we need to stabilize things
and so
i think there would have been an effort
to do that i don't think we had that
chance under biden because as i said in
the book as soon as he saw biden take
control and as soon as he saw the
disgrace that
occurred in afghanistan he was going to
take what he wanted and there was no
need to talk to us
it's funny how
the news that and life works out
sometimes like the president trump's
first impeachment was based on this
phone call with this then very obscure
at least here
uh the guy who was a comedian vladimir
zelinski the new president of ukraine
asking him to announce this biden
investigation you say first of all you
say that call was more i don't know
self-destructive than it was
and maybe unnecessary than it was
criminal right
right right i don't think there's
nothing criminal in that
call uh and
i just thought it was a lot of
i thought the whole thing with giuliani
trying to drum up uh getting ukrainians
to investigate biden was stupid was a
stupid idea
uh and it ended up hurting the president
but uh
you know i don't think he should have
been impeached over it
you write in the book you you don't
think it's
it's you don't think the party should be
going back to the trump well next time
any plans though i'm guessing no no
plans to get back in the saddle if under
president desantis or haley or pence
you're you're you're done with
government
uh um well i would say i'm done with
government uh
i have no real desire to go back into
government but as i say if the president
needs you to do something uh you know
you're disposed to to listen to that
because you're doing it for the country
but i doubt i would go back to the
department again it's a it's a very
i think it's one of the hardest jobs in
government and
having survived it twice
i'm not sure i would go back again
i think it's a tremendous opportunity
for republicans going forward i think it
could be another
reagan era where the republicans
dominate through several elections and i
think we need the right leader
to lead us in that and help restore
america to make america great again
that's what it'll take it's not
something we can do in one term it's
something that requires
three terms or four terms uh to to
accomplish
wilbur's book is called one damn thing
after another memoirs of attorney
general which one damn thing after
another was it was his title about by
the
way
which which damn thing yeah
there were so many of them
there were so many of them but you know
i i'll never forget the day where well
you know once
mueller went up to testify to me that
marked the end of the russia gate
nonsense uh once he went up to testify
during the summer
of 2019
and we were quite happy to put that baby
to bed
the very next day is when the president
had his phone call with zielinski and
we were on impeachment so
that was definitely one day after liam
barr thanks a lot good to talk to you
thank you
[Music]
from the fox news podcast network
download and listen to everyone talks to
liz fox business's liz clayman talks
with entrepreneurs and executives about
inspiring and motivational stories
subscribe and listen now by going to fox
foxnewspodcasts.com
subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
david marcus
what's on your mind the numbers are in
as if there was much doubt about it a
new study has revealed that some of our
nation's bluest big states
underperformed on covet response
compared to ruby red florida and others
the number crunching which combines
deaths economic harm and educational
impact was done by the committee to
unleash prosperity and it's a doozy
at the very bottom of the list to the
surprise of absolutely nobody who was
paying attention are new york and new
jersey the empire states handsy
disgraced and former governor andrew
cuomo was heralded as the leader of the
world needed on covid just two years ago
but according to the study his state and
others with widespread lockdowns had
high age adjusted death rates they had
high unemployment and significant gdp
losses and they kept their schools shut
down much longer than almost all other
states
meanwhile as the nation continues to
emerge from covid even in democrat-run
cities dr anthony fauci of all people is
telling americans it's time to assess
their own personal risk of the virus dr
fauci a man so risk-averse he wouldn't
place a bet on the sun rising in the
east
while it's great that fauci and other
leaders are finally coming around the
idea of living with risk so as not to
destroy the entire economy and
children's education what the study
makes clear is that this should have
been our government's attitude all along
it will not be easy for former
proponents of strict lockdown to accept
this data but then again they were the
ones insisting we all follow the science
the plain obvious fact of the matter is
that states like florida which opened up
as early as late april 2020 never
experienced the kind of death and
destruction that detractors of governor
ron desantis warned of it wasn't human
sacrifice as some in our coveted
hysterical press put it it was a
calculated risk and it paid off
today in china which gave us the virus
and the inspiration for lockdowns we see
millions again
forced to isolate themselves in their
homes remember when people complained
why can't we be more like china back in
2020 does anybody want to be like china
today would any sane person even think
of closing down our cities as we did
ever again
sadly we shouldn't hold our breath for
studies like this one or even eventual
congressional covid commission to dent
democrats appetite for lingering
restrictions like new york city's
ridiculous workplace covet mandate
leaders like mayor eric adams can't get
it through their heads that basically
anyone who wants one can have a vaccine
today and be protected from severe
illness put another way it's over these
studies are important because they all
show the same thing which is the
lockdowns were a mistake to begin with
and that maintaining them long after
their original purpose of keeping
hospitals from overcrowding was achieved
harmed the lives of millions of
americans
nobody is expecting a round of apologies
from the democrats who got all this so
horribly wrong their response will be
very vague and nuanced focused on what
we couldn't have known at the time but
many people did know at the time
including world-renowned scientists who
were basically censored by our leaders
and by big tech platforms just as
important as assuring the obvious that
lockdowns can't be repeated is for us to
examine closely how and why so many
terrible decisions were made in our blue
estates
did the personal desire for power
influence those governors was it just
inchoate fear that led them to shut it
all down
whatever it was the debate is now over
new york was wrong florida was right and
everyone needs to accept it i'm david
marcus columnist and author of charade
the covid lies that crushed a nation
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
download lauren green's lighthouse faith
we sort of think that god has nothing to
say about our pain and suffering god has
nothing to say about our sex life and
the truth is is that god is very much
has spoken to all of these things
subscribe now at foxnewspodcast.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes